minimum size is three million I think
the biggest company we have does about
six million a month we've done that
three million to 30 million jump six
times now we just really know what that
looks like and so we look for businesses
that are right at that range that have a
good leadership team that have really
deep expertise within some sort of thing
that they're teaching because that's a
big lever like how good you are at the
thing matters a lot now we know the
businessing around that to really
optimize and and scale it and drive
profitability add acquisition channels
increase lifetime value decrease turn
all that kind of stuff taking companies
from three to Thirty that are
internet-based founder-led businesses is
kind of the bread and butter and that's
what we do at acquisition